es una reunión que algunos califican de
clave para evitar una crisis alimentaria
marisol jefe de la unión africana se
reúne con vladimir putin en sochi este
viernes tras recibir una invitación del
presidente ruso el jefe de estado
senegalés busca un avance espera que la
reunión logre liberar las importaciones
de cereales y fertilizantes que se han
paralizado como consecuencia de la
guerra el bloqueo ruso ha hecho
vulnerable a áfrica el continente
depende en gran medida de las
importaciones ucranianas y rusas en un
intento de reforzar la seguridad
alimentaria el presidente senegalés hizo
un llamado a sus homólogos europeos esta
semana y parece que le han escuchado el
martes durante una cumbre en bruselas
los líderes de la unión europea
intensificaron sus esfuerzos para
negociar con moscú un acceso seguro al
puerto de odessa con la esperanza de
sacar el mayor número posible de
productos baratos
las conversaciones entre sol y putin se
producen después de que dakar se
abstuviera en una votación de la onu en
la que se exigirá a rusia detuviera su
ofensiva en ucrania senegal aprobó la
medida tres semanas después casi la
mitad de los estados miembros africanos
se abstuvieron o no votaron en estas
resoluciones esto por miedo a las
represalias de los rusos